what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down these spoilers for
my academia chapter 326 which features
the first ever meeting between all might
and stain this is something which has
been on the cards for a pretty long time
as stan's admiration for all my is a big
factor in why he began killing fake
heroes and of course all might himself
then wanted to have a talk with stain
after the villain was put in tartarus
prison the name of this chapter is who
are you a title that refers to the fact
that all might is now unrecognizable
compared to the image that stain would
have in his head as you know he was
locked up when all my weak form was
revealed to the world
just before we get into the full
spoilers don't forget to sub to the
channel with notifications on for weekly
spoiler breakdowns like this and as
usual let me know in the comments what
you think of the chapter
okay so the chapter starts with all my
driving his car while remembering his
last conversation with izuku he goes to
kamino where deku vs class 1a took place
and sees part of his mask lying on the
ground and this is referring to
midoriya's mask he then looks at his own
statue and remembers his talk with
aizawa before the war when azawa said
that just by being alive he's already
helping many people however oman himself
reflects and says that he can't do
anything for his suffering disciple and
that he's just holding everyone back
this is when stain appears pointing his
sword at all might and saying that these
words are an insult to a great hero at
this point stain doesn't actually know
that the person he's talking to is
almight but all might recognize his
stain and says that he couldn't talk to
him in tartarus like he wanted stain
replies saying he doesn't know what he's
talking about and all might then
realizes that stain doesn't know about
his thin form since like i said in the
intro he was locked up in tartarus the
former number one hero then introduces
himself but stain says that he's lying
so in order to prove what he's saying
all might briefly transforms into his
muscle form to prove it but even with
this dane still continues to doubt it
the villain says that skinny uma is an
imposter and asks why he came to the
holy land of a hero to lie and dirty his
name all might replies that maybe he was
always lying because he created a false
image of himself because he couldn't
stand to see the injustices around him
and the end result of his efforts is the
current terrible state of hero society
he says that even though he put his life
on the line he couldn't help his
disciple and after that he didn't even
have the courage to talk to him at ua he
remembers the scene of the civilians
handing the umbrellas to the students
which shows that all might was there
during achako's whole speech and
everything that happened he just didn't
have the courage to step forward and
reveal himself that is actually really
sad when you think about it because this
guy was the former number one hero he
was idolized by literally everyone and
right now his confidence is just so low
and i think there's a few things that
contributed to this i mean number one
the fact that he has no power he feels
useless but number two the fact that
deku doesn't listen to him and number
three the students in general they if
you look at this scene in season four
they were kind of like disrespecting him
in a way because he was trying to engage
with them and they were just like
where's aizawa like they didn't really
care that all might was there and so i
feel like this moment in particular it
kind of cemented to all my that the
students don't really need him
stain then jumps towards all might as if
he was going to attack him but instead
he only pulls him out of the way because
he saw a woman arriving they both hide
his stain tells almighty to watch and by
coincidence the woman here is the one
who almost saved in kamino who was
trapped under the rubble of a building
all for one tried to blast her with an
enhanced air cannon and yeah i mean
obviously she clearly would have died if
all might didn't intervene here and it
seems that you know as almost like a
repayment for that she goes to the
statue and begins to clean it and
removes the sign that says i am not here
staying then poetically says that the
embers left behind by all might have not
been blown out even by their strongest
of wins and have been passed on to a new
group of people who have turned those
embers into a huge fire that continues
to grow
all might begins to cry as he watches
the lady clean the statue and stain says
that he is unable to recognize almighty
at the moment but if he really is the
true hero he admires he should use the
information that stain obtained from
tartarus and kill him putting an end to
the hero killer he throws a knife on the
ground near almighty containing a piece
of paper with the information he was
talking about he then finishes by saying
that this is all for the sake of a more
just society and at this point omar is
still crying what stain said there about
a more just society so that is basically
just his mantra like the reason he was
killing fake heroes and the reason he
was also killing the petty criminals
like you know he was trying to kill
shigaraki he killed the nomu the reason
he was killing certain villains as well
was because ultimately stain's goal was
to make a society that was more fair a
society that was more just in his
opinion so he's never really deviated
from the ideology and the reason he
wants all might to kill him is because
oma is a true hero and you know back
during the hero killer arc he said the
only person who can kill me is all might
so he's just fulfilling that prophecy i
guess
that being said i don't know about you
guys but i highly doubt omar is going to
pick up a knife next chapter and just
kill this guy like that's not all my he
doesn't do that i mean even when he did
try to kill off one that was because he
was like the most evil person in history
you know with stain he's a bad person
he's killed people but i feel like all
my isn't just gonna stab him and that's
the end of it what i think is more
likely is that in the coming chapters
instead of killing stain all might will
work with stain because you know
whatever information stain has from
tartarus that is going to be valuable
and i guess whenever they get where
they're going to go which is probably
you know the location of shiguraki and
awful one whenever they get there stain
could be of help you know he has a
pretty decent quirk he has a lot of
skill so i think stain will end up
helping almight rather than being killed
the chapter then ends with the woman who
was cleaning the statue looking up at
the sky and realizing the rain is
stopping and yeah that's the end of the
chapter
be sure to let me know in the comments
what you think of this chapter and are
you of the opinion that stain will be
killed by all might or do you think like
i do that these two will actually work
together whatever you think let me know
and until the next one peace out
you